tu as fait une carrière incroyable raté
l'état participe à de nombreuses
émissions et ta carrière de comédienne
maintenant tu fais de plus en plus de
deux téléfilms de fiction sur tf1
notamment en 2012 puis participe à la
troisième saison de danse avec les stars
tu avec le danseur christian millette et
tu finis quatrième de la compétition ça
reste un beau souvenir ça ouais ouais
mais ça reste un bon souvenir parce que
j'ai appris énormément de choses
en plus des deux ans que je connaissais
pas voilà lâché vue d'affiner la danse
j'étais venu faire des jeux regarder
[Musique]
même
au cha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
briller
je
[Applaudissements]
diakité ah mais moi je j'adore les gens
qui savent danser pour moi c'est déjà un
exploit
vous pensez bien vous pas du tout et
vous virgin et vous danser bien roach et
c'est vrai alors limoges a fait le plus
rire
loris et celle du danseur qui se claque
a vu cent fois
mais même une semaine et je sais qu'on
va rigoler la regarde c'est l'image nous
a donné le risque d'image qu'elle
préfère
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en tout c'est son muscle ses déchets je
sais c'est que j'ai d'actrice à bouche
alors l'émission préférée de laurie
parce qu'on demande tous les jours aux
invités maintenant leurs émissions
préférées
c'est la maison des maternelles sur
france 5 mais oui eh ouais non mais
c'est normal non c'est ce à quoi il
répond à toutes mes questions
c'est ça mais c'est vrai que quand on
est maman la maison des maternelles même
moi qui accouchent il ya deux mois c'est
vrai que j'adore il ya une bonne
ambiance et on embrasse agathe lecaron
gardez vous avez une petite compil d'arc
à regarder alors là c'est beaucoup sur
un point c'est que tout les vieux ne se
ressemblent pas il faut pas s'en faire
10 et les viols devant n'est pas dans un
film pornographique moi je trouve ça
vraiment dommage mais c'est comme si on
avait tous le même visage se seraient
nulles et l'émission pas tous le même
bout n'a pas fait mal non il ya des gens
cassent ce n'est pas parce que vous avez
un vagin de coupe est non pas du tout
6il toucher vaginal sont beaucoup moins
douloureux quand on a des doigts louer
fin c'est sympa c'est vrai on n'y pense
pas voilà c'est sympa et on peut jouer
on peut mettre la queue de damier en
bouche sur le souhaitent
voilà on peut toucher je voyais les
matériels a raison il faut bien
travailler sont périmés après bah oui
c'est un 10 sport par exemple l'agent
vous parle vous ne vous en rendez pas
compte je travaille mon père aimait
danser vous adhérez vous mais chez moi
j'ai toujours travaillé les ravisseurs
et me servir cette casse et des
noisettes et line et aurait on attendait
parce que je crois qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui peut passer je disais que c'est
important travail son périnée par
exemple moi j'ai tellement travaillé que
je peux casser les noisettes avec coco
[Rires]
d'autres choses alors elle c'est vrai
que les maternelles pour toi c'est le
bonheur en ce moment puisque tu vas être
maman pour la première fois petite fille
nina qui est né le 12 août
non non tu rajoutes les magazines people
à la con ce sont gourés sur la dalle est
née quand l'eau bat pas le 12 août 11 un
peu avant le 10 mai entre elles sont
gourés sur plein de choses donnent
toujours croire c'est manon est né en
août
c'est bon voilà lé ne redoutent pas les
12 chez les changer c'était un garçon en
fait c'est bien le 14 mai voilà ça n'a
rien à voir
l'émission les émissions qui détestent
plus c'est comme elie semoun hier le riz
c'est les émissions de téléréalité et
comme ils font des tests de culture
générale dégâts ils ont été confinés
pendant toute leur scolarité je pense
regarde femme qu'elle célèbre chanteuse
française a interprété l'hymne à l'amour
dit ah tu amie vitaa et diam's victor
mes chiens pas moi elles font des
chansons d'amour et genre quand j'écoute
leur musique j'ai envie de pleurer
qui a écrit la fable du corbeau et du
renard alors tu as dit assia les
fermiers le fermier en écran
suit agoraphobe de quoi ai-je peur
anthony soit famille quoi vibrer les
souris et les rats et les souris c'est
pas assez
tiens moi j'ai les gens j'aime pas les
rats si j'achète 7 débardeur à 9 euros
combien vais-je dépenser et à marie
cette fois 9 bat 71e à un malaise non
plus le dire c'est que j'ai compté sur
mes mains et où il faut quand même bien
sûr mais j'y crois pas je sais c'est que
c'est trop énorme même si je pense que
tout ça est et ruquier et je ne
comprends pas l'intérêt pas je joue et
je vais parce que vous pensez que c'est
tout
nous par exemple voilà une livre voilà
on met pas de chanter moi j'ai besoin
d'amour entre un peu car je me sers des
pères aussi si vous voulez
[Musique]
c'est avec un ami
écoutez je ne suis pas bien je faire un
malaise vagal équipe trop alors les
basques caniculaire les plus marquées
laurie on se souvient tous et il ya
quelques semaines donald trump qui est
atteint du comité 19 mai après quelques
jours à l'hôpital il revenait à la
maison blanche
la première chose qu'il a fait c'est
enlever son masque on sent quand même
qui galère un peu respirer regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ce soir c'est ce soir c'est
exactement encore parlé d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure vous allez voir vous montrer
des images folle de donald trump dans un
avion les missions qui délai qui te
manque le plus aux riches peuvent
comprendre
c'était le hit machine 19 et g soit
passé au hit machine
ouais je m'en rappelle à je te regarde
et je t'ai coma ou mais c'est frais et
repris ton tube je serai ta meilleure
amie
c'est la première émission où je suis
venu chanter mon mon titre en fait et ce
qui était un peu bizarre c'est que
c'était un peu comme une boîte magique
c'est à dire qu'au départ je suis arrivé
dehors et c'est un arrive au studio il y
avait tout plein de gens qui attendaient
pour être dans le public dehors et donc
je pas pardon pardon excusez moi pardon
je veux juin chanter et c'est les gens
me regardaient mais c'est qui c'est là
que tu passes devant tout le monde
je fais les missions les gens étaient
dans le public je ressors ces mêmes
personnes
je peux avoir une photo je vais avec
dédicaces et tous ces thèmes est
vraiment là où isabelle sur les billets
souvent très étrange à vivre en fait
regarder rester
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'eia
ouais ça fait du bien de voir ça comme
ça